Okay,
and why?
Behold is the moat that isn't my
brother's eye,
but consider us not the beam that is in
or how will you say to that?
My brother,
let me pull out the motive of the NIH
and behold,
a beam is in nine Onei.
What you might be wondering,
what a beam is.
A moat is the dust speck
and a beam is a very large piece of
lumber and so the issue is not so much
the blindness of others even though
there's as much blindness among others
as there is in as there is for you,
but the issue here,
the advice here,
the description here is you should be
concerned about what's interfering with
your own vision first and you should
leave other people the hell alone in
relationship to that,
and so if you're a mode of being in the
world is if you would just act better,
things would improve for me.
Or if you identify the evil and the
catastrophe is something that's outside
that someone else needs to fix,
or that someone's responded someone
else's responsible for,
then then you're not going to fix that
and you're going to remain blind to the
things that you're doing and not doing
that make things not go well and so it's
just better to think,
all right,
I'm probably blind in many,
many ways and maybe there are some ways
that I could rectify that because it's
highly probable that you're blind and
all sorts of ways.
I mean,
it's.
It's in fact it's virtually certain and
so it's just more useful to think,
how is it that I'm wrong in this
situation?
I'll tell you something that I learned
to do when I was arguing with my wife,
which happened quite frequently.
Because when you actually communicate
with people,
you find out that there's many things
that you don't agree on and that's
because you were actually different
creatures.
And so if you're actually going to have
a truthful conversation,
then you're going to find out that you
don't see things the same way.
And then you can either pretend that
that's not the case in gloss over it and
then ended up in a 30 year silent war or
you can or you can have the damn fight
when you need to have it and see if you
can straighten it out.
So now and then we'd get in a situation
where we were at loggerheads,
we couldn't move and it would spiral up
into hate speech,
let's say,
because yeah,
everyone laughs because they know they
manifest plenty of hate speech towards
those they love.
So one of the things we learned to do
was when we hit an impasse was to
separate and to go our own ways and to
go sit and think,
okay,
look,
we're at this
unpleasant situation.
We can't figure out how to move forward.
I'd always think,
of course it's her fault.
Obviously it's her fault.
Least Ninety five percent.
But maybe there was something I did that
contributed like five percent to it.
And so I would sit and think and ask
myself a question,
which was,
is there anything that I did in the last
six months that increase the probability
that this impasse would manifest itself?
And I'll tell you,
you have no idea how fast your mind will
generate an answer to a question like
that because there's undoubtedly some
idiotic thing that you did that you know
that you remember that increased the
probability that you're going to have
your hands around the throat of the
person that you love.
And then you can go tell them that and
then you can have a conversation,
especially if they do the same thing.
Say,
look,
you know,
here's how I'm an idiot in this
situation.
Now there person says,
well,
yeah,
it's,
here's how I'm an idiot,
and then your two idiots,
and then maybe you can have a
conversation.
So thou hypocrite first cast out the
beam of light,
and then shalt thou see clearly to cast
out the mote of thy brother's eye.
That's pay hard to argue with that.